SPEAK >> Bret: TRAVEL BAN 3.0
IN FRONT OF THE SUPREME COURT AS
CHALLENGERS MAKE THE CASE AGAINT
THE RESTRICTIONS ON PEOPLE FROM
SEVERAL MUSLIM MAJORITY
QUESTIONS.
SHANNON BREAM REPORTS SEVERAL
JUSTICES SEEMED SUPPORTIVE THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS EXECUTIVE
AUTHORITY OVER IMMIGRATION EVEN
THOUGH LOWER COURTS HAVE STRUCK
DOWN THIS      A VERSION OF THEB
DOWN THIS      A VERSION OF THEN
DOWN THIS      A VERSION OF THE.
>> THE JUSTICES HEARING ONE OF
THE MOST CONTROVERSIAL CASES
LAST.
MUCH OF THE ARGUMENT OVER THE
THIRD VERSION OF THE PRESIDENT
SO-CALLED TRAVEL BAN FOCUSED ON
THE BALANCE OF POWER BETWEEN
CONGRESS AND THE PRESIDENT WHEN
IT COMES TO IMMIGRATION AND
VETTING.
JUSTICE SOTOMAYOR OR ASKING HOW
FAR THE EXECUTIVE CAN GO.
>> WHAT I SEE THE PRESIDENT
DOING HERE IS SAYING I AM GOING
TO ADD MORE TO THE LIMITS THAT
CONGRESS SETS AND TO WHAT
CONGRESS SAID WAS ENOUGH.
WHERE DOES THE PRESIDENT GET THE
AUTHORITY TO DO MORE THAN
CONGRESS HAS ALREADY DECIDED IS
ADEQUATE?
>> JUSTICE ALITO ADDRESSED
CLAIMS BY CRITICS OF THE BAN
THAT IT IS THINLY DISGUISED
RELIGIOUS DISCOLORATION AGAINST
MUSLIMS.
>> I THINK THERE ARE 50
PREDOMINANTLY MUSLIM COUNTRIES
IN THE WORLD.
FIVE PREDOMINANTLY MUSLIM
COUNTRIES ARE ON THIS LIST.
THE POPULATION OF THE
PREDOMINANTLY MUSLIM COUNTRIES
ON THIS LIST MAKE UP ABOUT 8% OF
THE WORLD'S MUSLIM POPULATION.
>> OF COURSE THERE WAS PLENTY OF
DISCUSSION OF THE PRESIDENT'S
PREVIOUS STATEMENTS, INCLUDING
ONE REMOVED FROM HIS CAMPAIGN
WEBSITE CALLING FOR A "TOTAL AND
COMPLETE SHUTDOWN OF MUSLIMS
ENTERING THE UNITED STATES UNTIL
OUR COUNTRY'S REPRESENTATIVES
CAN FIGURE OUT WHAT IS GOING
ON."
CHIEF JUSTICE ROBERTS ASKING
ATTORNEYS IF THE TRAVEL BAN
WOULD BE PROBLEM FREE IF THE
PRESIDENT SIMPLY DISAVOWED HIS
EARLIER COMMENTS AND THEN
REISSUED THE BAN.
>> IF TOMORROW HE ISSUES A
PROCLAMATION DISAVOWING THOSE
STATEMENTS.
>> THE THE COURT SEEMED SPLI
>> THE THE COURT SEEMED SPL
>> THE THE COURT SEEMED SPLL
>> THE THE COURT SEEMED SPLN
>> THE THE COURT SEEMED SPLG
IDEOLOGICAL LINES.
KENNEDY MAY ONCE AGAIN BE THE
SWING VOTE.
>> Bret: THERE IS ANOTHER
RULING ABOUT DACA THAT RAISING
EYEBROWS.
>> ANOTHER JUDGE HAS STRUCK DOWN
DACA.
THIS ADMINISTRATION'S ABILITY TO
PUT A STOP ON IT.
OTHER JUDGES HAVE SAID YOU HAVE
TO FREEZE IT, THIS CHURCH IS
GONE FURTHER SAYING NOT ONLY DO
YOU GOT TO PROTECT THE PEOPLE IN
THE PROGRAM NOW, YOU HAVE TO
START OPENING UP TO NEW
APPLICATIONS.
WITH THAT, THEY GIVE THE
ADMINISTRATION 90 DAYS TO FILE A
NEW MEMO TO SAY WHY THEY ARE
JUSTIFIED IN SHUTTING IT DOWN.
IT WON'T START FOR AT LEAST 90
DAYS.
THIS JUDGE IS SAYING YOU HAVE TO